yeah let's go in and it was fun yeah I
never witnessed gangster David Choi for
her any gangster David Choi stories dude
I know I know a crazy David Choi story
did but I get one of the funniest
[ __ ] thing I don't even sure if he
[ __ ] remembers but then at the same
time I think so it's so funny because in
in a stand-up set oh [ __ ] Popo baby
but in a stand-up set I wanted to tell
this David Choi story yeah number one if
you guys don't know david choi
davidchoimusic yeah out of all the
youtubers that I've met that I thought
would have been really well kept
together this fool is a disaster awesome
is his persona is like squeaky clean and
I just play this folk when he is
training ugh yeah this full one you know
I'm gonna just tell the story anyways
and if David if you want me to take this
down I'm still not gonna do it so so
this is one time we were out in k-town
right and mind you like David is a funny
[ __ ] dude I love every time I see
this did I get really happy but David
was a little blasted you know Korean
people we drink everybody has fun yeah
but as we're at k-town we're walking by
right and there's his girl wearing this
flannel shirt when next to her boyfriend
and dave is walking down we're all drunk
and David goes what's up flannel shirt
and the do goes yo sup man you talking
to my girl he goes I [ __ ] you die this
what David David it goes from zero to
100 he goes yeah I'm talking to your
girl [ __ ] we all stop her like that's
not right dude what the [ __ ] I looks at
everybody else and he goes did he just
call me a [ __ ] right 100 yeah and then
David out of nowhere
unnecessary he goes I called you a [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my [ __ ] confused and he goes
what do I do
he goes yo did you forget call me a
[ __ ] again right the dude is like and
then you know Abe Abe comes up he just
kind of grabs David away and if it's
like five three two by the way feistiest
[ __ ] yeah it's always a short guys that
get everybody else in trouble dude and
then Abe kind of grass him back he'll
calm down and as David's in the distance
he still goes he still somehow managed
squeeze what's up [ __ ] the distance and
this dude gets [ __ ] angry he's
getting mad now he goes to I'm gonna
[ __ ] up your friend and his girlfriend
to calm him down or whatever he should
have done it earlier the [ __ ] and a
brawls about to go out and I [ __ ] you
not one of his friends come comes in the
guy's friend comes up and he goes yo yo
yo chill chill chill chill chill
cool cool cool it's whatever it's cool
it's cool he tries to squash the beef
and as he squashes the beef he comes the
baby goes dude David
y'all him a big family yo can take a
picture selfie what David he takes his
[ __ ] friend away
David's [ __ ] wild dude Dan called you
he's lucky that guy wasn't crazy you
know I think I think he would've got
swung at if it just didn't come out out
of nowhere and it was so funny it was
kind of funny because it was so
unnecessary yeah you didn't because
David was in the wrong he was like hey
are the dudes girlfriend just walking
next to him I don't know where he just
goes yeah oh yes it was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
throw me off the David's [ __ ] funny
man do you think you know what what do
you think about all this like YouTube
people calling each other out for fights
and stuff
oh I mean definitely you could you you
already know people are doing it because
it's the hot thing to do yeah I just
think it's just a really dumb thing to
do because you're actually gonna get hit
yeah some of these people they're
they're planning it out don't like the
recent one with [ __ ] long they're
still doing them too there's a few other
kids that are gonna box that around you
too because they are it makes money
which ones are they I don't know I saw
somebody training with Roy Roy Jones
Jones jr. it was another YouTube kid
that's gonna box or some how do they
have access to these people they got
money
oh they got Mad Money you you think
these [ __ ] huge boxing stars are
gonna say no if they're gonna charge him
my 400 500 bucks a session yeah yeah
they're not saying they don't give a
[ __ ] they're just gonna train him they
are they're gonna get their ass beat
that's why I didn't really care to watch
the logan paul in the ksi one just
because i like boxing as a sport yeah
I'm not there to watch some low-level
amateurs fight not to say that they
could have [ __ ] somebody up for sure
and they're just if they're just in the
middle of the street those two will [ __ ]
somebody up yeah but if I'm trying to
watch a boxing event I'm not gonna watch
to low-level amateurs fight so don't you
want to see him get hit in the face I
would want them to get hit in the face
with somebody who can really do damage
to them oh you know to me because those
two weren't gonna do much damage to each
other it's all planned that's what
that's what I want people to wail on
each other like they hate each other
I did I never saw that I mean for sure
with Logan Paul - I mean the guy I think
the guy wrestled in high school yeah
that's what I heard yeah I think he
wrestled in high school and he's a big
dude man he's like a 6-3 or some [ __ ]
like that yeah in that case I kids like
tall to me he's like 6-1 6-2 or some
[ __ ] but yeah there's some big beefy
dudes so if you see them fight though
they will crack each other but when I
saw a little clip of him fight I was
like this is the worst fight I've ever
seen in my life it was just it wasn't
entertaining if someone challenged you
you think you'll fight them it depends
on who it is it depends on who it is and
how long I plan to train so also you
would actually entertain if idea if I
could just boxing or kickboxing or
anything how to kick boxing if I if I
would I would do kickboxing I have to
know who it is we have to be around the
same weight we would have to be the same
way we'll do it by weight class and then
on top most likely you're heavier than
them and I would like to I would like to
I need to train though so I I would
literally drop it you know how my
personality every [ __ ] I would drop
every move to Thailand for two months it
would have to be a mature rule so we
need headgear shin guards though oh who
would you like I don't know somebody but
you don't even need a train for that yes
different but it would it would be fun
I mean I would prefer to fight somebody
that I like though because I want it to
be I want competitive competitive you
want to fight someone you like or
somebody that I just don't have any
emotions for I want to fight someone I
hate because if I want to if you just
buy somebody we hate we could just meet
up and just Duke it out alright right
you know yes knock on the door we'll
have some [ __ ] I'll take a rock and I'll
smash your face open ghetto style yeah
but if it piece makes time yeah peace
baby stuff but if it was something where
it was like competitive it would be nice
it would be somebody that I could fight
that I know like it loves the sport as
much as I love the sport and then we
could see where we go from there and it
would be kind of nice to clash and see
what happens yeah um but number one I
won't be able to because Merida will
never ever let me and I think it's like
she's so Marilyn but people don't know
about Muriel she hates violence of any
sort what if she'd consider violence its
football violence to her she was my dad
I can't even watch football Oh your dad
doesn't watch ball I mean I could watch
MMA here and there yeah but when she
sees violence in the like in front of
her face she [ __ ] hates it so when we
used to get into fights back in the day
arguments and I would raise my voice and
yell it would actually like like we'd
scare her a bit because she would see
that a lot from her dad so her dad you
know just a Korean parent just being
really loud yeah breaking [ __ ] in the
house which is very Asian yeah she hates
seeing that [ __ ] so when she sees that
it actually scares her so if she sees me
even doing Muay Thai and then we do
something's too serious she [ __ ]
hates it doesn't want to see that side
of you she does like it either like she
when she when she saw me get super angry
once it almost made her want to break
the break up of course so like that's
one of those things that I don't really
want to gamble with yeah yeah and even
if it's like okay well it's one thing
but for forever in the rest of her life
she will remember that one time I went
in and I got my face bashed in and it's
gonna [ __ ] with her head oh you got
another one were you in or or I would I
just knock the person out but you know
but you guys already know what it takes
to be a fighter and I don't know if I
had that it takes it takes a lot cuz
it's not even just the whole you know
drilling and training constantly getting
enough hands to get in into that ring to
fight
there's the conditioning part of it
right and after your conditioning you
get proper sleep proper training how
many how many how many times are you
reviewing what you're doing it's just
cyclical over over and over and it's a
full-time job and even then you've done
already yeah time job cuz you're gonna
fight I want to I really want to but
it's a bucket list yeah it's a bucket
list eh but then I keep going back and
forth like there's a side of me that's
like oh it's a bucket list thing you
really want to do it and then like and
it what I like about fighting it's kind
of like the culmination of everything I
like about athletics and sports like you
have to do anything addition you have to
run and do your roadwork you have to do
the drilling and the technique you have
to do the sparring and get the sparring
and like there's a lot of aspects that
you have to train and so I really like
that but then the other side I mean that
kind of scares me a little bit is like
there's all this head trauma people with
CTE oh for sure and then I'm like I'm a
business owner I'm a dad do I really
need to have CTE and trauma to the head
is that the smartest thing for me to do
just for a bucket list so I keep like I
probably debate myself like every single
day about it like if I once I get into
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu tournaments for